lydia queen hi queen hi queen
oh my gosh i i could i could go like
this with you forever hours hours
we're going to do it one day i promise
absolutely
okay so two hour episode and sadly we
see you go home was that a blind side
were you expecting it
uh no i totally wasn't um i like i had a
pretty good sense of what was going on
but until it was all switched i think at
the last minute um but yeah i was so sad
and then them cheering when i left
tragic i was like
so sad
yeah all of us cheering for you at home
yeah
well when you got to the merge beach you
entered this alliance of eight do you
ever felt like it was really a solid
eight or was it just kind of you know
for game and for show um i think it
definitely was and i think they stuck
together i just think without me um
because you know at the end of the day
there was only five of us to vote for
you know so it was just like
automatically there's gonna be a
spotlight you know um
on us unfortunately um yeah i was
tragic
so were you surprised that it ended up
being you because we had physical
threats running up and down that beach
lots of people with lots of advantages
why do you think it ended up being you
no i truly don't know i mean like i
i honestly think at the end of the day
it came to like omar was like not he was
the only one safe from his alliance
right so it was like it was me hi
jonathan marianne and lindsay all up for
the thing and they
i think they were trying to pretend like
them four were like not as solid but
they were very solid and i don't think
omar was gonna let anybody go um from
his alliance and everything and like
literally like a master class of a move
like amazing move on his part and
everything but it definitely i think um
it just i think it was just like an
unfortunate way like played out and
everything because i really don't think
i really don't think i was on anybody's
radar until the
twist and everything
yeah right right it moves quick it moves
fast so fast yeah what can you do
i mean come and talk to me the day after
and call each other clean that's really
it right
right right
well is there something you feel like
you could have done differently
um you know at the end of the day like i
was a very like social player and like
i i know i like that's like such a trap
right like to be like what could have
done differently what could have done
that but it's like i think at the end of
the day like you're just trying to make
the best move for yourself and in the
moment like you're just trusting your
gut and being like all right this is
what i feel is right um and
i i don't know i think
um mistake why i don't know because it's
like i really like i didn't really
backstab anybody i really like did it
like i was just like trying to i was
trying to play under the radar like i
was trying not to make a big spectacle
because obviously like you can see
people implode and premaritals are
trying to play too hard and i was like
not trying to do that like i was just
kind of like yeah i'm going with the
numbers going with my lines trying to be
a loyal player and everything but
unfortunately that still got me in the
end was so like maybe i probably would
have like maybe played a little harder
you know but i was just kind of like i
don't i don't i didn't in that moment i
was just like i don't want to
you know make things worse for myself
you know because i'm already on the
chopping block already so
you know
it's
so quick it's like you can do nothing
and then sometimes end up on the
shopping block and it feels like that's
what went down and when you went to
tribal council who did you think was
going home
um
i thought it would have been either
jonathan or marianne truly i thought
like we were like i don't remember who
we were putting more votes on um but i
remember
we were trying to split them in case
anything was played um so i i was just
like i just wanted to not be me so i was
just like yeah yeah we'll we'll put our
votes on and yeah
so a moment that surprised me and i
think a lot of people in the audience
was seeing that hai actually voted for
you so were you surprised to see that
hai voted for you and did you feel
betrayed by his vote
um obviously at the end of the day
everyone's gonna make make the move that
they're gonna make it was just more
confusing in the way that it was like i
think he
realized the numbers were not gonna go
his way uh but it was i think like i i
as as soon as that like happened i had a
feeling like who it was because also
like i wasn't surprised by mike because
we were not really working together
strategically but like without i think
it was yeah it was just like confusing i
was like because i could have easily
been a number i had been loyal up to
that point and everything and i don't
think the votes were going his way so he
just like jumped on the bandwagon but
then he didn't tip me off either so it
was just kind of like yeah just cutting
me loose and i think he wanted to play
with different people i don't think he
wanted to play with me anymore um he had
obviously the amulet that we see and
everything and i think he just
he yeah
he and omar got him i think and i think
elmer like twisted that like thing that
it's like oh like you know she's trying
to get out the big ones which i really
wasn't at that point like maybe later
but not then
you know you know
well if we can go back in time a bit
because you had mentioned your strategic
relationship with mike or maybe lack
thereof and you were an ally with high
so if we go back back in time to the
journey vote
you had a close call there so what kind
of happened with your relationship with
the vati tribe after that do you feel
like you were actually truly able to
trust them afterwards or were you just
kind of going along with it until the
merge
oh no we um we were all like no like
because because daniel and chanel were
trying to play both sides like they were
like telling us me and hi that we were
for and they were saying the same thing
to jenny and mike and um like after that
it was trust was gone like it was
just like a matter of time you know at
that point um because
yeah you can't like you can't play both
sides and then don't be so gung-ho when
you don't even like you don't like i
mean like dana did like he they did not
have the votes and everything so like i
mean he was trying to hardest because he
did he didn't want to work with them but
it's like at the end of the day he
didn't have to vote so like um
and he was trying to like play us also
at the same time and so we were like as
soon as that happened we were like bye
like he was done like he was done
yeah
oh my gosh well okay when i went on
twitter and there are a lot of people
who
found out i was speaking to you today
and they were all just saying you're a
queen they loved you they're sad to see
you go and i think that there's a lot of
parts of your personality that really
resonated with a lot of people so i
think one is a lot of people can relate
to the story you have about having a lot
of insecurities when you were younger
and then really working to build your
confidence so how did your time on
survivor impact your
self-confidence it truly like i felt
like especially with even just like my
body like our bodies are so capable and
survivor like really showed me that like
i was amazed of me being able to just
like like even just like do that puzzle
like when that was like i hadn't eaten
in like nine days like it was like
literally nothing like i was i was
running on just pure adrenaline and just
like my just the fat that i had on my
body already and she worked hard and she
kept me alive and she yeah
bmj pulls through
like oh my god like that thing was
saying it out there holy like that's why
i like i was like wow like it sticks out
it sticks out and so like it was amazing
to like be out there and just because
you're also worried about so many other
things like you really like can't be
caught up in your own
you know like insecurities and i i
really just was able to like let it go
and be like hey like yeah i did suck at
some challenges but then hey i still
prevailed and stuff like i still i had
my little niche like that i was like all
right i'm doing okay you know not gonna
be great at everything like we can't all
be jonathan like you know like we gotta
have the lydia's out there
um but it was really really awesome like
because
yeah like i like remember leaving the
game just like so confident i was just
like wow like i don't give myself enough
credit like even just like who i am i am
strong like as hell and i'm just like
i'm just like proud of myself like
because it really was out of my element
and so like and then of course like
we're not all going to like love
ourselves every day like there's still
going to be bad days and like that we're
like mean to ourselves when we don't
need to be but like even watching last
week's episode i was kind of like
wow like i like i like was seeing that
girl again and remember who she was i
was like yeah like i'm i'm so happy of
like the growth that i've done and
everything and i'm like i want to get
back to her like fully you know because
like obviously we go back into our old
habits like getting home you get back to
your old topic habits and then watching
it back again i was just like wow like i
like i'm just like harnessing like i
inspired myself again i was just like oh
right like right you're right like let's
go back to that and so it's been an
amazing just like experience and just
like seeing myself grow i mean obviously
in front of millions of people you know
but which is hey like i'm grateful for
it
it was awesome
um it's so touching to hear that you got
so much out of it because strength comes
in a lot of different packages
and i know you said that you're not
jonathan we can't all be jonathan but i
think that if jonathan is the goliath in
challenges then you're goliath when it
comes to memes and one-liners because
so many people thought you were so
hilarious this season yes
so i think you're an actor you watch
yourself on screen all of the time i'm
sure you've you've seen yourself on
screen plenty of times before
what was it like now watching you be
yourself on reality tv
oh it was definitely a weird experience
because it's like obviously with
everything else like you have a script
so you have a script and you know where
the story's going and obviously i love
what like i wish survivor was scripted
gosh that'd be awesome but like
unfortunately it's not and so it was
really like it was very like um it was
just very anxiety-inducing too in the
way that it was just like
i don't like i hope that i come off you
know even just like the way that i i see
myself and i feel like watching back i
really do come off just the way i really
am and i i wish there was more
parts that like we got and of course i
think because of the outcome of my game
i feel like there was points that like i
feel like my
voice wasn't shared as much as i wish it
was but i do feel like um it it's so
true to who i am so i really can't
complain like and i feel like it does
speak to
other people and that it's like i i've
gotten so many lovely messages being
like i see myself in you and that just
like that makes it all worth it and i'm
just so happy and i'm just like yeah
like yeah you can suck and you can still
do good like you know like it's it's a
it's an amazing ride it was an amazing
ride i can't complain
is there one moment that you wish made
the show
um
i wish um i i wish like my after my
almost going home with the jenny i wish
i had a little bit more narrative of
like my like my thoughts of it instead
of like other people saying kind of like
what was happening i wish i like i had a
little bit more of a voice in that um
but
and also we had um our first like camp
days like our first like three four days
of us like camp life and everything
those were i just like wanted like i
wish i could see that again just for
like pure nostalgic factor because like
i can i will never forget those days
like those were just so blissful we're
all like also after like pandemic like i
was supposed to play like before the
pandemic you know so like
yeah no yeah yeah so like oh my gosh
journey journey what if we were together
sorry queen queen
queen
[Laughter]
no no no that would have been iconic uh
but yeah so like it was just like though
i remember just like those first few
days just like looking at the stars and
being like wow like we're really here
it's lovely and it's like i i'm just so
happy to be here you know and i'm lucky
i hey i should have been gone that first
tribal i actually i should have been
gone so like it feels awesome that i
even made it as far as i did
lydia
queen thank you
we're never gonna forget you i wish you
all the best thank you and congrats on
this job i'm so happy for you i you're
thriving thriving so happy for you
congrats on your win again of course
you're an icon
um but thank you for having me this has
been a blast
you